you want to [ __ ] not to we're
streaming live and now start the podcast
mid word and if we just keep talking
[Music]
okay and we've been now now we've been
live the law for a few seconds live from
the all things comedy comedy festival
everybody it's the Nick America podcast
with Nick Youssef thank you thank you
thank you everybody
sold out room how many people I'm not
telling you but it's sold out all of
them we've stopped letting people in I
got to do a read okay it's right here
where I already said we're at the word
live from the ATC poppet and I didn't
we're at the all things comedy comedy
festival and we're recording live from
the hcc pop up podcast studio we're in
downtown phoenix we're across the street
from stand-up live and this festival is
presented by Bud Light the cityscape and
Tito's handmade vodka two things I can't
drink have you guys had any so you know
how it feels before the other thing Bud
Light absolutely which I've had enough
of in my life to say that it's good
that's what my dad drink that's fine I
like drinking like regular beers and
then once you're drunk switching the Bud
Light when no longer matters yeah it's
like having a it's like nostalgia no
yeah we're talking about this sponsor
this way yeah it's the it was the
official beer of my dad watching WWF
wrestling growing up every time I think
of Bud Light I imagine him sitting there
after work watching back when they
called the WWF really that and being
like leave me alone until it's over
question answer maybe was your dad's
favorite the Iron Sheik that's a legit
question who was his dad's favorite oh
he was a huge Hulk Hogan guy mm-hmm and
then because he was so huge on Hulk
Hogan hated The Ultimate Warrior
you'll get mad when he was on TV because
remember when he took his belt yeah he
got he got legitimately upset like it
was awkward in the house and I was so
attached to it because he was we watched
together
that when the ultimate warrior beat him
I remember going into my room and then
crying for a Hulk Hogan really yeah what
was also 9 but you know I guess I was
gonna guess 30 yeah yeah this is a few
years ago that he had that fallback plan
that worried Rover speedboat remember
that show no was that ultimate what no
Hulk Hogan no no the speedboat and solve
crimes Thunder in paradise
Jack Lemmon Sun was the other good old
errand coming in strong well cousin was
the most marketable of all the rest of
all time maybe not now anymore actually
he took them over he said he's got a
power he took down Gawker he created the
mold really now you have to be calm like
a I mean he was like he went viral
before there was going viral when it
came to wrestling and all that sort of
stuff you know you set the mold for ya
like all these other wrestlers like I
just all I got to do is do a whole they
decided now that you know it's all set
up obviously but the outcomes it set up
what I wonder how he's like hey I'm
gonna be the guy let me hear this
blizzard I'm gonna be the guy who just
always wins right I don't really have
any special thing but I'll just never
lose and then I'll be a huge champion
yeah and then they were like yeah okay
you'd be that guy don't they just gauge
it off like live popularity I think
that's how they used to do it alright
everyone's clearly cheering for this guy
you gotta do promos I think people like
they pitched characters and stuff like
alright here's my thing I walk around
with the 2x4 I love America no all right
no works right now I was in that place
they call you hacksaw jim duggan oh he
would be now yeah he'd be like the
populist candidate of wrestling hey but
yeah yeah I cried when the Ultimate
Warrior lost or won yeah when Hulk Hogan
lost oh they're all dead
yeah bogan Huggins how many homeless
people have you seen walking at you here
yeah and they're not as aggressive as
they look like they're about to be when
they're like walking down the street
suddenly and like they're taking their
shirt off just cuz it's hot and I'm like
here's where I die here's a Dean exhale
most people in Los Angeles all most
people I was smoking a cigarette outside
the hotel yeah and his homeless guy came
up to me took a cigarette butt out of
the ashtray
and I'm like oh he's about to ask me for
a cigarette and he goes can I get a
light I'm like oh you just want me to
light your [ __ ] shitty half cigarette
that's a homeless person in Los Angeles
would have asked me for a cigarette and
then for money and then maybe a place
ignoring one this morning and he was
just nearby us me Eleanor Daniel Neil
and Ian Edwards and then he comes over
to make his pitch you know and he goes
hey listen I got this hoodie I want to
zip it up I've got one arm can you help
me it's that true yeah that's Henry all
looked alike I don't know you guys paper
scissors rock to see who helps us gallon
was like okay that's fair pull your
hands out of the way I don't need to
touch you at the forum there was a
moment where like I'm not positive yeah
I feel bad about that because you know I
want to help somebody but I also like I
don't want your [ __ ] bum come on my
hands or whatever so my I'll light your
cigarette for you and I could touch my
lighter yeah but then you kind of does
that move like let me touch your hand
and kind of prevent the way nomic don't
let's not have any interaction
physically but I'll help you yeah I
don't know why that guy didn't have a
pullover hoodie well I got that one yeah
I mean one he found it he's all hundred
degrees every day yeah zipping that open
might be the barista was telling me down
the street that like the homeless
population like triples once it gets a
lot cooler weather cuz she was like this
is a great outdoor living city really
yeah I would imagine you go to the park
and there's like 75 homeless dude where
do they go before is it shelters than
those summer and they migrate like birds
they just like travel around it
differently yeah but I know they just
have to leave for a month homeless like
native yeah really yeah cuz they get the
money from the government and they're
like it's summertime I'm sleeping
outside and doing all the crack the
crack yeah what do they do the rest of
the time they live on the rez hmm I
don't know what's a reservation Indian
really yep wait it's Native American or
Native Americans what are the Croatians
personation they call them their first
nations first nation is what they're
called yeah so and then it's like you
know two-thirds first nations and then a
third of like homeless people no they
become the homeless
oh they're like cool government money
for them giving a smallpox take that
money turn that into good times in
chests yeah they go down by the river
and shirt and those sleeping outside
outdoors all day but and then you know
September comes around it's like all
right back to homes have you done drugs
on an Indian Reservation was that you
know I don't know that wasn't me who I
feel like I'm not sure I would thought
to think about it I mean I've smoked
weed probably nearby one but well I mean
don't people go to those reservations
and do like peyote that is a good thing
yeah I want to know he did it but that
does is this Jeff Duncan he's been
offered it before I'm sure it's probably
off at it now yeah right at one right
now Ted buddy I wonder if you can just
get you can do whatever is it I mean
it's that was basically a sovereign
nation [ __ ] where you go there and do
whatever you want yeah you can blow up
fish with dynamite on him that way
really where they just drop a dynamite
anything and then just scoop up for them
now we were uh we were scuba diving you
could hear a boom go off Wow and it was
like yeah the drop Madonna sonically her
if you were underwater would you feel
that my sound carries amazing underwater
mm-hmm so you're like where's that but
it's like two miles away no way yeah Wow
yeah it carries real well you just go
like this and something and people like
what when you're underwater you were
underwater and then you would hear that
dynamite go off like a mile away I don't
know how far away but they're like it's
not close bro didn't seem like when you
were underwater how did that sound it
was like this what was it feeling I was
excited for that impression like wow
he's got this daddy's been working on
this for a couple months I want to know
it I wouldn't do it thinking like I'm
gonna nail this and then I feel like
there's no way I can make it sound like
underwater dynamite I like to commit the
commitment of like I know how this will
go but no no I got nothing
got nothing did you have to answer for
for America a lot when you want overseas
loves America overseas
really that's [ __ ] what people say
he'll love us that we have the best
[ __ ] movies great music good fashion
no I mean like this year I'm gonna talk
about like you know most people just
heard of who our president is okay they
don't know anything about him they know
we don't like him that's about it but
there's no head shaking or like you know
haha now it's your turn I know they all
have cooking people to jacobi and
Indonesia you just he sold off one of
the islands to show China yeah for his
own money they teach all their kids they
get seventy thousand whatever like
Islands the exact number and now it's
one less [ __ ] leader sold one really
that's like in America where they're
like how many flags are how many stars
on the America at the 48-52 yeah does it
change there's a Louisiana Purchase
counties who are do we ever lose in game
though yeah yeah yeah I would impress
people out there they're like we have a
lot of islands here I'm like 17,000 347
like what how do you know it's called
Google yeah yeah we're not for [ __ ]
him a sketchpad
are you ever don't how are you with that
you ever gone back smartphone to
smartphone I don't know my life because
I don't think any of us thought it would
last this long
I didn't think I'd make it to a year I
didn't I didn't either especially like
six eight months like he would hang out
and he would like give a tongue beating
ear beating to people yeah about how
like oh I don't need it I don't know but
then when your words like let me Google
something real quick on your phone I'm
like ah you can't have your cake and eat
it too yes I can why not you all have
[ __ ] cake give me some of your cake I
don't care okay yeah at this point it's
like it's almost inspiring I'm like
maybe I should downgrade I thought of
just getting rid of my data plan so I
could do it when I'm around Wi-Fi I
don't need it any other time yeah what
do you really need it for take pictures
take them you can still take them yeah
yeah I kind of want to do cuz I'm like
I'm slowly like deleting social media
apps and things like that were like
removing myself from from all that and
it feels [ __ ] good it feels good I
got banned from Facebook once because I
think Tebow
took Tripoli's phone
and you know he was like I love big
black [ __ ] yeah and then so I saw that
and I posted on his Facebook page I was
like oh here man I just saw a guy
[ __ ] holding this hog yeah you must
love this Conda yeah it was massive and
that Facebook's like your band I'm like
what am i banned for and then they
private message me that like yeah I
thought it'd be forever and then I felt
free I felt free and then like a week
later like I'll let you back in and
they'll do that anymore
okay and then it was just back to this
[ __ ] prison yeah yeah I want to I
want to select maybe it's hard because
you can't ruefully remove yourself cuz
you all right well what about coming to
like a festival like this I'd especially
what with what we do you want to tell
outfit I can't remember the last time I
went on line and didn't feel like
depressed or like everyone's like
fighting and yelling fighting constantly
the best possible is some douchebag
saying I have the best wife here's five
great years with you like publicly yeah
which why I even do that but now you
look forward to those that's the best
possible scenario from that now I don't
look like or dudes I know looks someone
like being joyful about [ __ ]
something yeah even if it's like a plate
of food or like their child as opposed
to like here's why you're wrong about
everything that's ever happened it's
rare like I had so much fun of the
Yankee game it's just rare yeah get some
fun [ __ ] like that
well I had fun and then and then the
reply is like how can you have fun at a
time like there was some thread about
yeah why you're a piece of [ __ ] Reds
have ruined Twitter yeah um
Facebook and no I mean the last year and
a half of like you know election
coverage and stuff and Facebook everyone
I liked Metzger's theory on Facebook
that's why I likes Facebook over twitter
is because he goes on Facebook I write
something big and then you because
you're no one get an itty-bitty response
we need the bottom Twitter it's all even
spaced yeah so good you have the same
power as I do no not cool so he just
stays on Facebook and you start to see
the replies and engage sort of no yeah
it's just dogs horrible and you can't
say no to it so what are you gonna do
the first handful of years of Twitter
were like four
for jokes to me yeah everyone's having a
good time and the last few have been
like the stars of Twitter now are like
journalists Oh Sara Silva has written a
joke in four years and you're almost
like you know it's like irresponsible
among fans it's like hey man you know
can you write something serious it's
like I mean I went to Community College
so no I can't I don't know I don't know
international politics as well as I'd
like to think I [ __ ] do yeah you're
barking up the wrong tree here talking
about my dick every Tuesday from 11:00
to 1:00 yeah norm Corps people right
what is that what like you're not like
comics or artists or anything are you
you're all comedy sitcom all right
forget you you guys do you see like
Twitter I mean Facebook being too
bothersome you don't use it all right
that's good well I mean you gotta think
it was probably useful it brought him
here indirectly at least yeah indirectly
at least what was your gag that you were
mad about earlier you had a coke that
you were at I gotta give it to [ __ ]
Benson he's you get a gift first another
one sober
Ahri's very like temperance over artists
snappy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah sober
everybody so far is not relaxed I'm
sober American is snappy yeah bottom
line yeah a simple question is like wow
I know all your feelings yeah I know
yeah it's um like now it's like no so
you're gonna go right back to I never
intended to do this it's not like I'm
trying to better myself I'm proud of you
for doing it and sticking your guns and
having the integrity to actually do it
on on the last day though you're gonna
just get as high and drunk as possible
what's the plan no I'm not gonna try
like throw up I'm just gonna like drink
I'm just gonna drink again it's fun to
drink yeah yeah you know what I'm at my
friends and like they have a nice scotch
I like I'm like I want I want a glass of
that I don't need seven glasses what do
you miss the most like Ian ordered like
I miss pot or I miss I miss a drink
after a gig or I miss Polly when I don't
like a bunch of sets in New York
yeah like five six sets and a night and
then it's having a glass of wine or
glass of scotch at the end like at a bar
like when the stand just like chilled
like let me just [ __ ] enough traveled
from the club but just like relax or so
you missed the end of the night drink
yeah or whenever I smoking weed like
yeah sure I'll smoke with you guys when
soda or a big J or like yeah it's like
yeah for sure I do want some but I can't
have any that's what I meant that's the
one thing I miss about drinking it's
like that camaraderie the unwind thing
or it's like oh yeah everyone's gonna
like a happy hour let's have a good time
but every once in a while Mike you'll
see someone like chilling at the end of
the night like how you're describing and
have a drink and I'm like every once in
a while I'm like that would be nice but
for me it would be like the next thing I
know I'd be like how to end up in this
chicks apartment like where am i that's
like [ __ ] 9 a.m. you know and it's
just not worth it why can't we just be
[ __ ] moderate once in a while I know
some people aren't wired that way to
discipline you know it same as that
phone it's like yeah you're all radical
going to rub their deep rabbit holes
yeah and we had no like there's no
[ __ ] rules or boss over us a lot of
the time to be like don't do this at
this time and if you can't control
yourself that well then you you know no
one's gonna be there yeah I think
everybody has friends that have gone off
the deep end of like you know can't stop
looking at their phone to cancel I've
friends that I don't even know what
their eye color is correct I know at the
top of their forehead he's one of them I
know I know everyone's balding pattern
no one's eye color the lost art form is
a conversation is this for sure and I
think that's why it's a podcaster so
captivating to people because they're
listening to people being forced to have
a conversation and then they're
listening to and they're like oh I
remember conversations as they're
listening to it and looking at it on
their [ __ ] phone and not having that
actually organically having one Rogan
was saying he's not addicted to it to
his smartphone I was like dude I haven't
had a full meal with you in 10 years no
way yeah yeah come on give me a break
Wow well I favorite thing to do is when
people say like just control it just
don't check it that much I'm like okay
and then I wait and I wait for a moment
where they're not supposed to be
checking their phone they know it like
an agent or something or a club owner
that's in the room yeah checking you
know when you're like you know you
shouldn't be doing this right now and I
just go over their shoulder and I just
come behind a minute ago
no no I need to do it for this uh-huh
well yeah because it's always in a
reason you need to be doing it in your
mind everybody's busy and you're going I
leave it in the car or something yeah or
if I'm gonna sit down and like write or
do something I'll like I'll go and leave
it at home
this is - or cuz you tell you all go to
a like a diner a coffee shop with no
Wi-Fi and then you have your phone which
has all the internet I leave it at home
and then I'll sit there and then you'll
like have a conversation with somebody
yeah you know talk to the waiter I'll do
the gig doing a gig in Chicago and I
didn't take an uber I took a cab and I
left my phone in the cab which you leave
your phone in an uber you can easily get
that back yeah you leave your phone in a
cab and you're like oh what cab was it
yellow biggest city in America like it
was gone so for like about 18 hours I
had to not have a phone and my phone
vibrated in my pocket 40 times in those
18 hours by the way there was no phone
in my pocket like fit like my left
testicle just vibrates every [ __ ] 40
minutes somehow is everybody okay with
that doesn't think it's weird but I
would go in my pocket I'm like oh that's
right I don't have a phone I probably
did that 30 times in those 18 hours till
I got a new phone oh [ __ ] my oh that's
right I don't have a phone you know what
I did I was on I felt like I was dead I
felt like it was a ghost like can
anybody see me yeah am I am I still
alive I was on a hike a few days ago and
I and I have my phone in my pocket and
it'll like sway around yeah yeah because
the shorts are light or whatever and I
was walking and I didn't feel it in
there and I was like [ __ ] that started I
started to turn around and then I looked
in my right hand and I was holding out
oh I've done that move before I'm
leaving my apartment I'm like talking to
somebody I'm like I can't put my [ __ ]
phone there like you're on it oh that's
right thank you
but it's that kind of [ __ ] that makes me
go I can leave this at home for the
afternoon and not worry about an
Instagram comment or who's texting or
like Weinbach doesn't even have a phone
it just as a home phone which is [ __ ]
insane and how did he get here he says
he doesn't miss anything he print stuff
up how does anybody know that he's alive
you know is he alive is he cared about
he gets by though he gets by he'll email
you back tomorrow sure and call you when
he gets home now they get by he's a
great person to have a goddamn
conversation with sure because he's
talking to you not everybody else in the
world who does never met before do we
talked about racist dogs yesterday for
40 minutes
you don't whine buck yeah yeah for real
because we neither German shouts I
assume you mean German Shepherds yeah
the most racist dog yeah of course
Freddie's Locker dog died I'm like I'm
sorry man I'm sorry about your dog goes
no you're not you know that dog hated
you and you hated him yeah it's like
yeah he bucked me a lot at tennis DNA
like you seem cool but I think I'm
supposed to bite you I remember one time
just probably like right when like
texting started and everybody had like
flip phones and like the next thing you
said was the worst why I don't know why
you were the words you're the first one
to embrace it fully and you were like
texting man I can't talk to you today
okay you were you embraced it hard
texting I remember calling you one time
you go back I don't talk on the phone I
never said that
[ __ ] I never stopped talking to Duncan
Trussell we're about to go meet at uh
who's a guided like BJ Novak yeah it was
his birthday party okay so we're gonna
go to that and he's gonna come pick me
up but while I'm talking to him on my
flip phone I'm urinating in my apartment
and I'm trying to wrap the call up and I
go hey bro by the way this is what I
think about you and I flushed the toilet
and hold the flip phone right by so we
can hear the toilet flushing and then I
hang up on him and when I do like a it
shoots like a pocket shoots out of my
thing and goes right down the thing and
it's just completely gone it's like
completely gone and I go oh no this is
not good
ah how am I gonna know that he's here to
pick me up like I don't even know what
to do about this those of us who are out
$30.00 exactly which at that point I'm
and this point in time is a lot of money
to me those phones were indestructible
though like I wish they'd knock that one
well you don't know if I [ __ ] came
out in like an ocean in Malaysia call
that a loss some dudes using
right now calling back there's no right
now I get that phone back now and he's
like buddy are you there yeah yeah used
to be bad men weren't fun put on that
concert at the House of Blues a free
concert you were so mad at me so mad
because they were like would you guys
get off your phones and remember you're
looking up going no okay here then just
[ __ ] going right back to it we show
they're put on a good show no no
I'm addicted to good music and fun as a
bad band they have good songs you know
they don't yeah that was a better
rendition than they did her night at the
[ __ ] so here's not we're young it's
you are not young yeah yeah opposite
song the dude at the concert like was
barely trying and he was wearing [ __ ]
flip-flops and shorts and [ __ ] looked
terrible and then he stops halfway
through a series dressed like Ari yeah
basically yeah yeah
he stops halfway through a song goes oh
I'm sorry you guys not enjoying this
free concert we're almost done I'm like
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] Rock harder
nobody was into it you wouldn't notice
that they know when he did that I was
like I tuned out after that I'm like you
are a coward you shouldn't be on stage
oh man
he did yeah I started his own thing you
could tell they were gonna do it because
it was a played on his own they put his
name there look he's about to launch his
own [ __ ] band wait did he yeah I
remember one of the other guys from fun
ended up becoming like he started
producing a lot of Taylor Swift's music
and they became like a [ __ ] huge
producer I don't know what happened to
the singer that's why I didn't go
anywhere cuz he wasn't written songs
hopefully he's making coffee somewhere
in the bad never seen him live just a
couple casually so why do you stay there
[ __ ] intentionally not paying
attention to them because I was hoping
that he'd look over and see someone like
texting on his phone with like a baby
did he stop again no I'm gonna leave now
cuz I'm a sad rock star I'm rich in
talent I know I should have thrown that
was a heavy phone I should have thrown
it on stage that's my walk-up music
whatever people ask me about walking
music
that's on one foot it's the best which
one yeah yeah yeah by who
fun so you probably don't know that song
cuz you were on your phone no hear it
over the yeah they had even started yet
yeah that was a bad ban have you
listened to the new war on drugs record
it's good
that's a great at is good out yeah good
on isn't your in your podcast about
immigrants yeah it's about a the ethnic
experienced immigrants and stuff but not
always this is not yeah at first I was
like well let's just kind of talk about
like being in Phoenix and seeing what
happens and I know I know we can get to
the immigrants I know they should get on
our country no offense like hey we can
do a hard Segway through tomato climb
wall climbing why I don't know we've
known each other for 15 years now I
think
but you I 18 almost no really yeah how
do you know uh 35 I met you when you
were 18 yet you're 18 the story 2002 a
new 90 wouldn't allow me in I remember
the rules where you're not and I was so
I was happy to enforce those rules yeah
yeah I know I've said this before
probably on podcast even with you but
like the you came up to me as I got off
stage doing the open mic I think for the
first time at the Commodore and I walked
offstage and it probably went what like
sort of maybe okay it was good for open
mic yeah and that felt kind of good and
re walks up Comedy Store sure as I came
in are you really eighteen years old I
was like yeah he's like is it 21 and
over Club so I'm gonna have to ask
you're a [ __ ] walk me outside and he
goes this is the threshold to come in
line with get that foot of now you're
outside it was so fun it got to the
point
thank you everybody have a good night
let's go on March and past the line and
now stand right here are further yeah I
was seven years older than you but you
were the first one of the first people
to help me get a job there so it all
sort of evened out right now yeah we've
had a long history of constantly making
fun of each other for being Arabs and
Jews yeah it's hard for you because you
have to punch up
[Laughter]
you are lucky in that you get an
ethnicity that has like some cool
positive stereotypes you guys are all
smart ya value education yeah value
education all successful started looking
listen maybe not that one but you're uh
you're like kind of a rock star do I
think I mean you don't embody you don't
embody like Woody Allen Jewish stereo oh
yeah victim a Jew maybe yeah but you're
not like you know you're you're [ __ ]
like a rock star kind of attitude guy
you know I wouldn't go rock star but I
get what you're saying yeah I mean not
real wrought like fun rock star like the
lead singer of fun solo beginning you do
drugs you're [ __ ] partying oh yeah
yeah I'm not like my parents yeah yeah
you're the same way you had to clean up
from the alcohol because you couldn't
handle it what else
yeah I'm nowhere I'm nothing like but
that was my [ __ ] [ __ ] I do yeah
I would you were like taught by over a
while tough I've what [ __ ] yeah you
were single and you were drinking
Nicky Nick you sit would [ __ ] you would
you would go to bars and you would [ __ ]
yeah I think there's a part of that in
like 19's a comics but just as a man
you're in your early twenties and you're
in a situation like that yeah and if
you're single I was becoming an adult in
comedy at like the comedy store mainly
so as I did to figure all that out like
kind of in front of everybody
yeah you know it wasn't like oh I got
that all out of my system in my 20s and
now I'm doing comedy in my 30s but like
yeah I made all kinds of mistakes and
you know all in front of everyone's eyes
but um but all that was like a growing
up that was like all like a push back to
try and like be as like non-arab yeah as
possible yeah right for a long your
parents are both like ethnic like that l
cook they ROM cook you banjo yeah they
make Lebanese food at home they speak
Arabic they're very traditional some of
that [ __ ] yeah they don't ever make that
but I know I know a good place that
sells it really
it's like right down the street from me
unless feels but um but yeah next time
you're in LA we'll go there it's like
it's like legit food really I like that
they have nothing like that in New York
in Manhattan it surprises me there's a
there's a few good Lebanese spots in New
York there's one near you in the East
Village there's one in uh somewhere in
Brooklyn yeah I went out there and I
found I started searching all the good
like Middle Eastern spots and I found a
couple but did you have that sort of
thing growing up what did you push back
against your I didn't until I became not
religious and then it was like it wasn't
like [ __ ] you I'm rebelling it was like
oh what's this world
Oh weed is good yeah you know women's
their boobs feel wonderful right you
know but we go where your parents like
strict about your childhood and they're
like it was just like what you're
supposed to do it was no like strict it
wasn't like we need you to do this but
everyone else is not like anybody in the
school was doing the same thing Orthodox
Jewish everybody was doing it was the
same world oh you didn't go to like a
public really yeah it was just like all
of us doing the exact same thing there's
just the world you gotta you gotta
finish high school you go to Israel for
a year or two you're just gonna you're
gonna you know in hindsight like when
you look back in your life and your
child and all that what about that do
you feel as an adult was advantageous to
you now we're having that kind of like
strict sort of not strict but like
secular sort of upbringing non-secular
yeah yeah yeah I'm good at logic because
of the Talmud it's all logic based so
that's you know with 18 years of
studying that you start to like really
understand how to mm-hmm how to do that
right
what about like chants and prayers that
summon the afterlife what about the
demons that you conjure up yeah like you
know junior high high school I Q were a
you were among your own people I guess
there was no there was no less all of us
yeah there was no we played against
another Jewish school in our league and
then a couple of like private schools
that had to be some low-scoring
basketball game sure 115 to 9 I was 13
to 9 I was a center double-overtime 15
and 9 we're still tied at 4-4
in the ninth quarter the best was girls
middle school Jewish League and they
would say just head down dribble to the
corner as hard as they could to the
corner then pick the ball up and panic
and just like what yeah
final score for two every time for two
yeah or two you can get you that's like
yeah it's like a ninth-inning run if you
get any basket every sixth grade
basketball it's zero zero at the end of
the game and it's like at a soccer when
it's zero zero they just line everybody
up if anybody can hit a free throw the
game's over
I have drills yeah hey-up drills we call
the Jewish duck when you go up and like
lay it up and then slap the backboard no
it's close I'd like to see a Jewish dunk
contest that's as good as they could do
I wanted to shoot threes and my coach is
like you're a center I'm like I'm
six-three I should be a [ __ ] point
guard no not Jerusalem bro you're easily
the tallest kids yeah tallest yeah by
how far like two feet no there was
people there were six months yeah I had
some Israeli blood in me - so it's
tougher I never met an Israeli girl
until like I was like an adult I was
like they can look like that they look
good though right yeah you were the one
that pointed the difference out to me or
at the Comedy Store you're like see that
girl right there she can take but yeah
ever since that conversation you're like
here's how Israeli girls look here's
those far teachers are mixed they got
mixed blood they're not all super inbred
right I probably dated more Jews than
both of you put together
really yeah it just seems to be a type
of woman that seems to like me I dated
one Jewish girls I know why Jewish girls
like me but they do like all you have to
do is be my girlfriend is like be cute
in like me and I'm like okay we're
dating yeah that's pretty much the
[ __ ] standard or it had been it had
been Jewish just love me do you they oh
yeah
the point where David Taylor we would
like to see some girl like look at me
twice and then he would just go up some
like excuse me are just random question
are you Jewish and she be like yes how
did you know because no reason just
because they look but you haven't dated
a lot Jewish girls are you not attracted
to you know they're ugly but uh
I mean it for the most part they're
gross but there were super young ones
the youth overwhelms the grouse nests so
I'll go for it Jesus you're so unique no
no I've seen the ones you date and
they're ugly too my sister just like
dating your hometown you know you're
like no there's like a lot of good stuff
or you're like nah man under the baby
that's like that there's a lot of cute
Jewish girls there are there are some
for sure but mean it's not like there's
been three al but the Jewish look is not
a good look
I mean some for you or for them anybody
they're just it's not great if you look
Julie I don't know I don't know maybe as
a man too but for sure as a woman it's
like yeah like who's that chick from my
Star Wars who's the Jew the just lay the
new Princess Leia where she's Jewish
yeah but she doesn't look jewy right so
that's okay well Portman what about for
me yeah and or do I wonder woman - she's
really that's tell you that what hey I
met her what happened some horrible
movie and I was like finally got a
moment alone with her and I was like so
nervous so I said I was like um yeah
cause she's so hot I was like but my
dad's Israeli and she goes oh that's the
way then how'd you feel right after
terrible because the hottest she in
person super
stunner Braj she was funny on Tara alive
it's hard to get sense of humor yeah
seemed like it at least did you say
anything to her the rest of the time you
were there no but that isla Fisher girl
I could be that cooler around she was
there too
I could be cool around here cuz [ __ ]
super hot sover there so you like you're
nothing right yeah right that's
interesting that you had no like it was
all Jews how awkward years and I can't
imagine that were you awkward in high
school friends with everybody I was yes
were right I was every group like from
the stoners to the athletes to the black
people today yeah it was just always I
was just a funny guy in the back of the
class you had no enemies there's so much
like that now you fit into everywhere
you can yeah but I was very awkward and
gangly I've always been skinny I've
always been I have no ass I'm built like
an action figure it's just legs and then
back
I've always been like insecure about
being skinny and stuff like that but I
never was like combative or anything
like that right yeah I was I mean I was
not like that would you hang out with me
yeah I only ever had like two or three
friends at a time I think like and not
really so nothing's changed
yeah I'm not good at like I can't walk
into a setting and just [ __ ] let's
all hang out and just talk to anyone
about anything I get really anxious
really yeah I get real like it was
easier you know when you drink you'd
have a couple I'm the other way I get
really anxious when like I'm alone or
I'm like I'm not that's where I'm most
comfortable alone alone people I mean I
like a nice balance of it but I but if
I'm like four or five days where like
I'm not around people I get stuck
darling no way really
yeah I need to be around people I need
to interact with people I need it's just
how I am
yeah yeah I just got used to that sort
of thing like you know if you're if
you're not around a bunch of people who
can like you know judge you and tell you
you're different
it's that that's better than that you
know and then I'd have like I remember
having like one friend who doesn't win
like eighth grade his name is Mark
something I can remember and we hang out
and stuff and like we'd hang out maybe a
couple people he was also like friends
with all these like skater kids who like
were not like friendly with me really
yeah and I remember he was like going to
hang out with them one day and he like
was like hey man you know I'm sorry and
I was just like oh [ __ ] and that was
like they'll I was like I knew I might
that'll be the last day of her friends
because he's gonna want to go hang out
with these guys who were like we don't
want you know we don't want NIC around
and never can't buy me love when he
starts going with that with the cool
crew and then his friends like why don't
you eat with us anymore
yeah yeah it was kinda like when you see
those moments and shows like you
sometimes you're just like oh that
doesn't really happen but it kind of
like it's obviously a heightened version
for TV but like sure yeah you're the one
like laughing but yeah that's like a
real thing but so was everyone friends
in school basically there was no like
none of us are different when t-50 per
class for grade yeah then I switched to
her school with 60 people per grade yeah
so yeah raised friends I mean Pete some
people didn't like each other a little
bit but like yeah we all there was
nobody
I don't even Wow that girl doesn't know
I exist there was none of that
what was the first time you recalled
like a racial slur of some kind then
about five minutes oh no that's Thai my
first time yeah I was taking the bus and
Wheaton Plaza and these girls have one
of they bought one of those like punk
kids from another school have one of
those those birds that were like oh yeah
red thing they were behind me and uh and
they're going they were like putting it
up to my head and they were going oh
yarmulke pecker yarmulke pecker and they
just kept heading with it I was like so
scared because Jews are victims and I
was like nothing does how it starts like
nothing now I got numbers tattooed on my
wrist my dad's grandfather was like hey
another hot shower sounds good just goes
from there she's got to let it happen
Jews are great victims man when I was in
when I was in I think fourth grade
that's when and gentrification started
and it would like bus black kids from
black neighborhoods to white schools and
that was a big controversial thing but
what people didn't really ever talk
about was there was a small percentage
of white kids at that school that had to
get bused the other way to black schools
that was me no way real when I was in
fourth grade I I could walk to my
school's two three blocks yeah but I
instead how'd you take a bus 40 minutes
to a worst school of black principals
black teachers and she and it was like
thirty five of us that went to an
all-black school you were the minority
yes I went through yeah I went in and it
was just yeah why did you try like
Apocalypse Now did like take over yeah
yeah I like a bunch of black ears it
made into a necklace
this guy's gonna have to pump the brakes
yeah but in hindsight I will say it gave
me at a very early developmental age a
great openness to when I was older of
acceptance of acceptance of about how
much I like white power who else is here
everybody to just you know by the time I
wasn't when I was in high school like in
a Chicago area I was in high school and
like I don't know 300 graduating class
there was like 60% black it was pretty
even
little more black but I mean it really
not only gave me a good opportunity I
learned how to just joke with different
ethnicities right and what was a good
balance of like what I can and can't say
to to to offend people right you know
you could push it to that limit and
you're like oh my god this way it's
offensive and I think in hindsight it
was a good thing for me it was very
scared of her [ __ ] nine-year-old to
have everything completely different
yeah but by the time I was 13 14 15 it
was nothing but ya know they love love
like social education you can't [ __ ]
my fate my favorite part about black
humour is the just repeat a joke that
someone else just made and then get an
equal laugh for yourself yeah like you
feel like wow house it's watching across
the roads get the other side everyone
laughs and I'm like yeah that's joke
reparations yeah and I would say we're
even though yeah that doesn't work
though it does work yeah he said and
then repeat the joke which I guess makes
it that funny if you can do it twice
yeah yeah it took me a long time to
realize your stupid is a compliment what
two black yeah like he's so stupid I'm
like no I once got you're a crazy
[ __ ] and I was like mmhmm yeah
so how long were you in that school we
burned it down third grade fourth grade
and in fifth grade I moved to what is
now my hometown was write a scar you
were wearing a [ __ ] do-rag and you
had the whole thing gold chains gold
chain I beat box on my book reports he
said beat boxes book look at that that's
gonna come back
for blacks and whites everybody's a very
so that was your first racial slur my I
got called a terrorist yeah sorry
on a playground okay no not you knowing
you when you were at what age at what
age I was I think I was like 11 or
something what was happening then it was
well it was the first Trade Center
bombing a white guy wasn't it no and you
were wearing a vest of dynamite his name
was ramzi yousef we shared the same last
name so this kid came to school that's
like a black guy calling another black
eye the n-word you're like it was the
same that's like a kid's gonna have to
capitalize on that you can't blame a
child but I mean I guess I would have
been like our if it was a joke or
something but he was honestly asking me
a serious way he came to school and was
like hey our it was almost like it was
almost like hey are you know did you
watch The Simpsons last night it was
that kind of like hey did you catch up
on he came it was like hey are you are
you a terrorist like it was just like a
matter-of-fact like just you know cuz
we're gonna have class later I want to
know if your other way that matter of
fact if all interrogation went like that
no one have a problem with it I agree
and the other the funny thing is that he
had your last name so the only reason
he's white is because his terrorist dad
[ __ ] a white chick with the terrorists
yeah no I'm saying you chef it was his
last name but terrorists terrorists oh I
thought the kid okay was like John was
that the Oklahoma City yeah that was
Timothy McVeigh come on all right this
episode will not be available online now
I'm just glad no one's getting peed on
right yeah yeah yeah I call the
terrorists yeah he came up and goes uh
goes are you a terrorist
and then I'm eleven so I don't know what
that is yet and I was like no I don't
want it what is
he goes and so then he starts to explain
that his dad told him cuz I guess he
mentioned me and so he was talking about
students in school and he mentioned me
by my first and last name and his dad
goes oh you know that it was probably a
joke the dad was making you know or his
probably - I'm cut yeah you got you got
a terrorist in your school or something
because his dad probably watch the
[ __ ] news
yeah and then and he was convinced and
started telling other people you know
like Nick's related to the guy that you
know launched a terror attack on do you
think that kid was uh I don't know I
couldn't figure it out what it might
just knew that it was bad to be like
from the Middle East after that but do
you think him telling you that was what
made you start planning 9/11 sorry when
did you first start playing 9/11 I'm
sorry to put words in your mouth yeah
thank you don't be rude actually it all
shows how far in advance did you know
that was gonna happen yeah you know it's
funny is on that day I woke up and then
I went back to sleep
going and I woke up I saw and I think it
might be Terrace I was so tired I'm like
I'll wake up when they know for sure and
then I got back up like midnight by the
way that's the same way I woke up the
first abortion I had to get it was like
up all night I only able to sleep and
then I woke 10 a.m. she goes ok it's
done it was like uh I can sleep now
question that's how you were with 9/11
we're like okay it all works
sleep I've never slept before question
first abortion you made it sound like
you had like a weekly thing like you
have like a subway card one is free it's
like for a year to order but the second
one didn't tell me to way afterwards she
was like I had an abortion like three
years ago with your kid and I was like
oh that almost doesn't count though you
gotta be there for and go through yeah
well could you even go back and say that
out of years I was like do you want
money and she's like no and I was like
good job why would she even tell you at
that point I don't know is it though to
talk about had you talked to her
throughout those three years or she hit
you up three years later and then just
said that or were you like lunch buddy
no we were hooking up in a car and then
she was like hey just so you know that's
the perfect time like and you're hot and
heavy it's like ah Sh
just you know you're a lot more and
[ __ ] fertile than you think yeah I
was like well get back to stuck in this
so I can think this out come on guys
come on this is brought to you by all
things comedy special things it's to be
a prophet good God Thank You Chico Malo
that's delicious food you guys ever
knocked a girl up no no not that I know
of I had a scare with Aaron's wife once
about four days ago i fingered her with
my dick and then she's I really
shouldn't be doing this
Aaron's gonna find out about this and
then it was downhill after that I could
tell by the look on that lady's face
when we looked out they were gonna leave
Las Vegas I did some Las Vegas shooter
jokes on stage in New York oh you were
telling me about this yeah the first
time I got two days after it happened
pretty quick and the second time it got
audible boos first it was quiet now I
guess I'll move on then they were boos I
was like oh well now I'm talking about
new town also and then uh yeah that was
your point your backup plan just like to
gun violence in general shayanna and
then they complained about me
they went out to the club yeah and they
go the light-skinned black I was very
offensive yeah they were trying to
figure it out for like a while and you
take it as a compliment
no I said they need a better lighting
system yeah absolutely
you're mistaken for a light-skinned
black eye yeah what the [ __ ] is up with
the lighting in that place I know it's
only comes from like here and there the
right side you can wonder when I look
like two people on this edge kind of
like a muppet good sake I got that hair
okay what's your callsign for when they
bring you up for your sleeper cell work
is there like a specific code sorry if I
told you that we'd need a new call sign
dammit you're right so nice try that is
true nice try that was a nice try could
have really helped out Americans I get
annoying now the fight the terrorist
jokes no I don't care now especially
what it's like when your friends do it
yeah like I only get annoyed at
legitimate ignorant questions people ask
what yeah
like when like when they go like I met a
guy in his like wife and sister
outside of the Nashville what's the club
there um owners right here and he where
he left um so this guy comes up and he
was like this short kind of redneck he
did with like no neck and like a
sleeveless [ __ ] this redneck redneck guy
and then it's and he comes up and he's
like a man he's a knees not funny about
oh yeah so he comes up and then he goes
hey you know that was a really you know
funny show how long you've been doing
comedy just like and everyone was jovial
I'm having a great time and I go yeah
nice to meet and is that what was your
name again I forgot and I go Nick and
he's like what's your last name and I
said Yousef and then he got serious and
he goes hold of a guy was just he was in
his like forties okay so young yeah I
mean not you know he wasn't an old man
it was just like okay you're like stuck
in your ways and probably don't know
where you are you know and then he was
just like what is that here we go and I
was like I'm on Middle Eastern and he
goes and he goes uh you know the good
kind of the bad kind or whatever and I
laughed and he didn't smile back he just
stared at me and it's [ __ ] wife and
they're just kept looking at me and I
was like you know I'm from here and they
go you know what are you and seven I had
to explain that I was Christian and I
grew up this way they're like you know
remind him that I'm like ham I'm not the
kind of Arab to fear or some [ __ ] and
that's way [ __ ] worse then you know a
million of the jokes you know we make or
even if that stranger made some dumb
joke that's better than like genuine
concern that the guy you just finished
complimenting for five minutes is now a
guy you can't trust yeah mm-hmm that's
[ __ ] ridiculous that sucks um him to
have to do aware but to put them in that
position is really what what role do you
ever get negative like questions or
comments about being Jewish I know
sometimes sometimes went out what people
like are trying to hurt me online right
they'll be like Oh how'd you feel your
whole family died the holland get like
present-day
sort of like stereotypes or insults
about you and your people and your
you know that kind of thing nah that
might be like the like Nick
charlottesville kind of South and that's
just those people you know right yeah
nah Jews are like first of all in places
where none of us right they don't even
know we look like yeah they don't know
us to like to do anything and the place
with a lot of us it's like yeah nobody
really cares like in New York they'll be
mad like the [ __ ] Jews but when they
say that they're usually right you know
what's an example of that it's like
their push a juicer push you so if you
get cut off in lines like [ __ ] Jews
but then the same thing with like all
say [ __ ] Dominicans when they do
something [ __ ] Dominican like you
know sure yeah so it's like yeah no
you're not wrong I get it that guy
wasn't paying pretty [ __ ] Joey yeah
yeah okay so you hear way more than you
know it's like you're walking out on
that with the Yankees where are you
going where you going [ __ ] idea when
I pitch him about edible diapers but
another one I hear but a question I have
that is is one I hear a lot of Jewish
people refer to themselves as white how
do you how do you feel about that I
don't feel good oh you're talking about
I don't want them encroaching on my app
how where do you find yourself there
like a type of white sort of yeah I
don't even know what the answer to that
is in every city yeah so like you can be
ethnically the computer but they can be
Asian but that's like the raw Ringo
people that killed in Myanmar I feel
like there are different ethnicity or
like or like in China or the southern
Chinese or I forget those are the
Catalan people in Spain like they're
still like that that's similar
yeah like racially yeah like ethnically
they're a little different right well
right
forgot that Chinese the type of
ethnicity it's like four percent of
China's this and everything else is
Chinese okay so it's like ethnically
racially were white and ethnically were
Jewish so it's type of white I guess
okay you know but like a lower type /
yeah so it's like it's like are you
white or black that's it usually boils
down to are you white or black it's like
no or white based on that but it's like
if you give me like 30 things and it's
like I'll pull myself somewhere else
yeah sure sure I mean there are there
obviously are more things than
we have our own type of food our own
type of like yeah I mean culturally
actually yeah racially I guess it's like
cuz if you ask you know a Jewish person
you'll get a bunch of different answers
but if yes like a you know a white guy
from [ __ ] the south or something he
would be like Jews aren't white you know
you're just white so you get something
from Vietnam and so I'm from China like
they look different yeah but they're all
Asian yeah people would just say those
are Asians yeah but it's like I'm not
exactly but I yeah when you wear when
you narrow the focus obviously you're
like no we're not white were this yes
party Jews are more like you right would
you say you're white know some people
would yeah some peanuts a [ __ ]
everywhere it go everywhere I go there's
a different answer if it's down to white
or black you're white
I don't think of either of you two I
might or friends you know if you like
remove a lot of options
sure yeah if it comes down to white
you're born white a black than Latinos
or black usually white sorry I didn't
make the rules
water Mexicans black Mexicans are black
Asians fallin white except it is a
samosa racism like Cambodia they might
be black but no they're all white
they're all white they're all white with
me
there's like white supremacist listening
I could learn from this our guy gets it
the best is when that amazing race'
stuff was going on I was in the cover of
the white nationalist is that right
[ __ ] now yes and it was a link to my
video and it just let the headline was
Jew boys got the right idea
that is it still every three years you
get backlash every about every about 18
months a new crop of people find the
amazing races somehow on the internet
and they go nuts and think that it's
real again yeah but the best was like
they're like we like what he's doing but
[ __ ] I wish it came for somebody else
that's like it's like a time bomb it's
like a time release bomb it's like the
gift that keeps on giving
yeah I'll just get like I'll wake up so
I guess they're like 15 tweets like 75
or a hundred tweets I'm like somebody
finally doing something it was like some
radio yeah
that's nuts man yeah that really now let
me ask you this cuz always want to ask
you but about the amazing racist
when you were doing it yeah it was a
funny thing and the internet hadn't
SuperDuper blown up yeah first TG was
the first viral de janeiro first because
the pre day was on per for that and then
somebody when YouTube started so he
ripped it from those DVDs and put it on
YouTube yeah VHS tapes or DVDs or no
when Jarvis and I had that puppies video
we were playing football with puppies
that thing went all over the place it's
but it was like all like word of mouth
and and then you did that and then the
internet went nuts did you know when you
were doing that or have any idea that
this was gonna be as crazy as it was
when you did it no that I eventually get
a [ __ ] show to cancel me and Kayla 12
years later like that no I had no idea
funny and harsh you're like literally
doing this and like all my friends all
laugh at this yeah I made a grand it was
yeah exactly
you wonder what what the backlash would
be now I don't think it would be what it
was I don't think it would be much more
understood as a joke and a goof now it
was back then I wouldn't let you do it
now where it looked as real as it did it
did have to make you look at looked that
real how would it be perceived how he
would get so mad they would get as mad
as they do right now when they just
discover for the first time like what
the [ __ ] is what's wrong with the world
right I think you would have Trump in
your corner if you did it now Ari's
working in the White House yeah I mean
there's good points his bad points he
makes some good point to make some bad
point which is why he's the Secretary of
State if I could get laid in the White
House that is where's the craziest place
you got laid yeah like I can't believe I
just [ __ ] at this place and tilt a
Comedy Store Eric's here this predates
Eric okay every room in that building I
[ __ ] air yeah there's a lot of places
I predate you I've [ __ ] in what is now
his office before you're in the upstairs
right yeah Mitzi's office yeah take out
yeah oh yeah oh you're up there yeah
yeah I [ __ ] her this stairwell right
outside there they used to lock that
though I'd sex in the sound booth above
the main room I had sex I found booth
about the main room Washoe is still
going
that's so much better yeah you in the
conversation who's next
yeah yeah it wasn't like one of the like
the main room choses like I like a
Vargas Maison kind of like I'll bring
everything you know yeah wow that's a
good one oh that is good yeah I [ __ ]
in a trunk once and now push it over
than she died yeah with the trunk closed
because of the Jettas had those
glow-in-the-dark you [ __ ] in a trunk
oh the Santa Monica it's like spooning
sort of how big boobs [ __ ] it back in
trunks man they're great they're huge oh
my god hope so yeah I [ __ ] outside
Mitzi's office once and then I found I
found Tebow's hat you you uh you're
[ __ ] outside there huh and he goes no
I don't stalk me I'm like for sure your
digs no I didn't here's your hat you
left it in this [ __ ] dark vestibule
where only people go to [ __ ] is like
yeah and then in my defense I'm like
wait what were you doing there oh yeah
it's like getting that D what Jesus
Christ so then you're you you think
you're white that's what your answers
yeah Jewish also like both you know I'm
Laird nobody's that whitish nobody's
ever one thing yeah no I mean whitish
yeah you're why this yeah new show to
follow blackish oh my god I'm so sorry
oh boy you're sorry rebirth and
apologize before you're done burping you
pop that was a pun apology burp my
favorite thing
I don't ask a lot of people people this
cuz the only most people would probably
answer but I feel like you guys would
yeah what's the most racist thought
you've had and had carried with you for
a while oh that's a good question
because everyone has one but I don't
think a lot of people like admit it
really late oh I used to totally think
that well I don't think Jews honestly
are just smarter than other people okay
that's a positive stereotype about your
own okay I tell you what other people
are dumber than Jews
every other ethnicity you think Jews are
on the top yeah
what about [ __ ] like Koreans like
Asian culture good work
Filipino I think Asian I'm smarter than
Jewish people yeah well that's a sign
you might be second smartest thank yous
recognize that I mean I still hold
Koreans have a good work ethic relax
with the smart okay run your own [ __ ]
bodega it doesn't make you smart one
thing that I know in Japanese people I
find myself still like if I'm driving
around or whatever and it's like
somebody's driving bad in front of me
and if I Drive by them I'm like course
it's a Mexican woman I still to this day
I hold that Mexican women are terrible
drivers okay then I don't know I was
just from experience but I know that's a
racist thing to think yeah yeah yeah for
sure but they've yet to prove me wrong
for sure racist thoughts I that I would
no longer think no longer thing or I
mean even if you do I don't know
no just that's one that still pops up
that I find myself oh no that's actually
racist oh that's racist but I mean and
but it still is yeah I do still have
that thought when I see a Mexican woman
driving and it's a shitty driver I'm
like of course god I had when I was a
kid I like the suburb I grew up in was
like mostly white and you grew up in
California right now yeah Los Angeles 20
minutes out yeah but it was mostly white
a lot of white flight happened to there
and like the seventies and eighties and
then and then some Korean some Armenian
and there were two black kids in our
school and that was it and then I
remember like someone saying like why
aren't there any like black kids in our
school where do they all live and none
of us had ever traveled outside of we
didn't know yeah and some kid was like a
lot of black kids don't go to school and
then he goes he goes and and a lot of
don't go to college or something like
that and then my only experience was
ever like watching it on TV so for like
for a whole school year I think I
believed that no black people went to
college and I would tell people that and
stuff and I was you know when you hear a
thing you let go tell people is if you
don't like you know
and then I met some older my friends
older brother was like you idiot that's
not true and I was like telling people
at school that it was terrible
I used to think that it's the
pre-internet I had no idea how do you
just spread it yeah I just if it came up
I'm like well you know we have like good
the kids in our school and we're lucky
to happen nope they're going at school I
don't think black people are stupid real
for sure as far along ago was that like
this morning for a while and then when I
got to when I was traveled through Asia
I thought like they were all gonna steal
for me earlier this year yeah me that I
just I was afraid of outsiders okay all
right and it so any new country or they
didn't speak my language was like I was
afraid of them until it hit me like well
this country is like super Buddhist and
peaceful like it's safer than America
yeah but I still had that fear of like
oh they're all gonna like robbed me oh
that's another one I had is for a while
I used to think like foreign people with
like heavy accents probably weren't that
smart I'll bet oh oh yeah yeah I had
that in college I know it's like where
does that even in my it's because my
parents have heavy accents and what they
didn't go to college but like they're
not dumb I'm like what the [ __ ] does
that [ __ ] come from and then you meet
people that are like and you have a
conversation with someone the heavy
accent they're smarter than all
xenophobia it's like we're the smarter
so we have to be the best everyone
else's from you yeah my uh my buddies we
met this guy in Denmark me and Bobby
Kelly and he's from Iceland and Bobby
was like hey you're really good comic
and he was like think it's got Arielle
charm and he goes dude for real like you
should you should move to America like
you're good enough to move there he goes
why would I want to move to America I
have like my country what are you
talking wouldn't obviously want to live
in America over any other countries like
it's just this bias we all have yeah but
I had that in a screenwriting class in
college where was a workshop class be
there like 10 pages everybody gets it
and then two days later everyone gives
notes yeah that's one woman she was
African
and I would always take notes like yeah
whatever and then it hit me towards the
end of the semester
she said something I was like really
clearly insightful and smart and I was
like oh I've been ignoring all your
comments all year because of your accent
it's crazy yeah interesting yeah and I
was like yeah you're actually pretty
small but it's like I couldn't see
through that accent like no way can you
be people used to do that to my dad like
at job sites and stuff because and they
would just assume he didn't know what he
was talking about you know exactly where
to lay the dynamite exactly yeah you
know where to hide it and when to when
to time it you know how to wire that
cell phone right to that briefcase yeah
he's like this is where the foundations
are on how the building will come to me
everything collapse on itself right yeah
yeah but yeah they would give him they
would give him [ __ ] oh just second
guessing like I know this better than
anyone here just because I don't speak
English doesn't mean and you'd have to
hear a lot about it yeah as frustrations
with people and then it would just have
to work harder and you know show them
who the [ __ ] was boss eventually they'll
break that down when you actually get to
know somebody face-to-face and you
actually see them as a human and it's
like oh I get it I got ya
but until people do that it's like
you're this other yeah you know i tec
see what it is you're everyone likes
clarified in this like mystery zone for
me until I personally get to know you
right and you can prove to me that
you're not some sort of threat or
surrogate or anything yeah yeah you're
just like this right and then like an
ambiguous other zone yeah yeah everyone
needs a version of what you had like
going to another like school or part of
town where where everything is like
flipped in Reverse so you can experience
but you know if that had happened to me
when I was 19 or 18 it would have been
different because I those four middle
years where I just you're 9 you're not
biased towards anything really you're
just like a kid they were just kids they
just the difference was one jump rope in
my white school double dutch when I went
to the black school
there was the only difference that's
funny it's there faster at jump rope
that's it that was it I do remember when
I was playing I would go play basketball
in the park Sligo Creek Park and I was
long you know and I was younger and I
was pretty good
and when I black when I block people
shots they were just calling a foul if I
blocked it out of bounds with a get the
ball anyway they like I will not accept
thing block by something like some
Jewish kid so it's like that's a foul
like whatever it's your one other way
that's a lot of fights have been caused
by people's self refereeing games oh
yeah a lot of fights a lot of shootings
we're gonna have a basketball rematch
yeah we do oh sorry 410 ah this is good
thank you for doing it both you yeah
sorry I'm sorry opened your cup you plug
anything or whatever I'm releasing this
on on Tuesday I want a plug is this
right here there's got to be some sort
of guy to take it out and you need some
Rogen's face no just just take the skin
yarmulke bra no uh I think that works
like Bill was over there going what the
[ __ ] my way did we die they run
commercials he's not watching them sell
to get going
the stem-cell research good luck with
that you need a new president just rub
it in and just grow like [ __ ] you
know an hour it's got a big arm right
here is just picking [ __ ] up I would
love an arm out of my head yeah a real
mohawk back not that jump [ __ ] skip a
step mohawk yeah that's funny odd cast
pun strong could I do with Tebow sports
check that out of course skeptic tank
yeah and my new pot 92.7 the pod which
comes out at the end of the week I'm
excited about it's like a big morning
radio a lot of fake town yeah it's
really really funny yeah thank you thank
you 92.7 the pod I went on there to
promote my shows that week in the local
it's gonna feel like classic like you
know the your grandparents are it is in
the forties and fifties shows and you're
like how is that how is that how people
got entertainment but like this is gonna
be like the 27th oh man yeah all the
commercials are fake all on everybody
and all things comedies involved in it
and everybody's playing different parts
and characters so it's really elaborate
but it's gonna be a lot of fun so tune
into that as well and of course
punishing sports okay and then we got to
thank stand-up live the Tempe improv
Chico Malo everybody at all things
comedy this has been a wonderful
festival so really much really fun and
thank you to everyone that came to this
live recording hey let's all kill
ourselves yeah
suck it
[Applause]